next we have Shelly stall she's the
assistant director for the American
Geophysical unions data management
assessment program she works with
scientific data repositories to improve
their data management practices with the
ultimate goal of elevating how research
data is managed across the globe
Shelly's diverse experience as a program
and project manager software architect
database architect performance and
optimization analyst data product
provider and data integration analyst
provides her with the capability and
development of practical and sustainable
data management practices thank you for
joining us and I'm humble too so so let
me tell you first about a GU American
Geophysical Union and one of the
interesting things is first of all we
are worldwide so we are beyond just
America just beyond all the states
there's 144 countries and we have 20
scholarly peer-reviewed journals largest
earth and space science journal in the
universe why is that because we actually
have scientists that have been on the
space station and we have scientists
that have sent probes out into space so
it's very exciting we will be
celebrating our 100-year anniversary
very soon so that's very exciting
scientific meetings i'll tell you a
little bit more about those and we have
a fabulous magazine which you can get
the online copy of right now if you go
on to eos org and it's written for folks
who aren't necessarily scientist so that
you can enjoy what's been found and
discovered and it's brought to you in
the words that you that are that you and
I can understand and this is our message
here's we're galvanizing our community
so let me keep going here's all of our
journals just to give you an idea of the
breadth and depth of what we have out
there the scientists that submit their
public there ought their research for it
to go through the entire process and
each of those journals has an
editor-in-chief this year geo health
we've already heard some speakers talk
about how important the environment is
and how that impacts
our health and our ability to live the
you know in a healthy community so we
recognize that and have a new journal
this year here's Yeo's I'll keep going
through all of that let me tell you
about our fall meeting so I don't know
of how many of you have been to
extremely large events but we've got
30,000 scientists that come together to
present their research this is
phenomenal there's an awful lot of
interesting collaboration that takes
place and everything from oral
presentations to posters the top picture
there is a very small portion of our
poster Hall it's like two football
fields long it's huge we were able to
draw a pretty significant keynote
speakers Elon Musk was there last year
which was terrific and that's me a
selfie with DJ Patil gotta tell you is a
big Cinderella moment for me I guess I
spent about an hour and a half with him
just talking frankly about the things
that we do at age you with data so that
was pretty awesome and we also have
within this community a challenge to
bring improve data management practices
across all of the different scientific
domains so we're doing that with our
data fair and we're doing that again
this year so we targeted towards the
researchers helping them improve their
data management practices through things
like this so we have a data position
statement at age you and this is a
really big deal it was written and
implemented in the 1990s where hardly
any publishing house was doing this sort
of thing so we data within our
environment is a world heritage we don't
purge our data we preserve it so that
earthquake that happened you can't get
that data back we want to keep that data
forever so in our mind our life cycle
goes on and on those climate models they
have hun they have a hundred years worth
of data in them they're huge anything
we're trying to do an important
longitudinal study to see changes like
that then models are massive in there
that kind of data to ingest so here are
the challenges within the community when
it comes to data repositories and the
folks that are working with data we've
got mandates we've talked about that
yesterday and today and i'm going to
tell you a little bit more the value of
data being able to curate it where's not
enough time and not enough money and not
enough expertise in each of the
different data repositories to do all
data at the same level of quality so
that's a challenge how do we do that can
we automate that wouldn't that be
fabulous and some of the other
challenges let me tell you about a
couple so here's the OSTP februari 2013
anything that is funded by the
government for research will be
available openly available including the
data so that was a little bit of a scary
moment for all of the federal entities
that have their data not necessarily
easily available and that's going to go
into effect I believe in a few days
October first and we did help one of the
repositories actually meet some of those
goals and I'll tell you about that
shortly but here's an idea of the kinds
of data that we have coming in this is
just Noah so we've got satellite data
we've got data being pics picked up from
instrumentation on airplanes into
instrumentation different buoy networks
which is many many movies that are all
connected together putting their data
into a single location but it but it
gives you an idea of the variation and
the difficulty and this this is just
climate data this was published by one
of our authors Jonathan overpeck and it
was a few years back but it is it does
show you that the the model volume so so
models generate their own data so the
data coming out of models as well as the
data that's being generated from all the
instrumentation is exponentially growing
and the challenges with actually having
to access
that being able to analyze that having
computer systems high performance
computing that's robust enough to handle
is extremely challenging and getting
harder every time we put up a satellite
it has more instrumentation with more
volume of data that's coming back down
to us that we have to be able to ingest
every second of every day and be able to
handle that and curate it and manage it
and then process it this one's fun I
borrowed this from Leslie wyborn Leslie
is a she's a scientist she's in
Australia and she she works with us on
some of our projects and she was trying
to explain to her community and the sku
as well because this is perfect there
are really two kinds of data that we
work with one of them big data which is
that heavy volume coming in from the
satellites and constant Earth observing
systems and then the other one which we
call long tail which was came it was
originally coined some years ago where
it's if you think about taking a look at
what's happening in a particular
location the permafrost that we were
just talking about that's a huge issue
the melting permafrost so if you go up
to Alaska and you go to measure all of
that not only do you need to take a look
at the permafrost which you also have to
look down into the solid earth and above
into the atmosphere and you need to know
about the hydrology of the area what's
the water vapor like what's the win
what's happening with the wind and you
take all of that kind of data and you
put that into your analysis that's long
tail data those are different kinds of
data that I've be curated differently so
that's challenging it doesn't always get
curated as the same level of quality all
of the time because you may not have all
the expertise looking at that in the
same way so here are the other kinds of
challenges with long tail data usually
for instance you're probably maybe see
the item there on it's located on a sea
drive so your researcher is out there
with their laptop right this is where
your date is landing and you're praying
it gets onto our repository work can
actually be curated and preserved so
here so those challenges so what
what age you decided to do two major
items one of them is to develop a
training program for researchers and
folks that work with data curators and
data managers to help them with their
skill sets so that's in development
we're really hoping that goes well but
for me I always brought on to implement
their data management assessment program
because I have a pretty significant data
background and so this is what I'm going
to talk to you about other things we're
doing we're also working with the
publishing community supporting the
effort to help them understand when
they're receiving data from the authors
for each of the publications these are
the things that you need to expect from
the data repository that's being used
and because publishers have so much
influence on how data is handled because
they require it in order to get the
publication out we're trying to help
them bring the standard up and make sure
everyone else is working to that same
standard that's really important for us
to spend time on and we also support
coming up with best practice for
different kinds of reproducibility
within the scientific world software etc
so all right let me tell you about what
I do so you have all those challenges
I've just told you all about them and
I'm saying you're that you have you own
a repository you may or may not in this
room but let's pretend now you how do
you solve it how do you actually meet
the objectives of what your repository
needs to do that can be pretty confusing
not not very many scientists or folks
that are managing the repositories have
a significant project management
background there's very little out there
within the scientific community for what
the best data management practices are
within those kinds of repositories so
this is what AG wanted to do how can we
help give a road map so that these folks
can more easily meet their goals and the
quality of how the repositories are
working together across the community
increases this is fabulous I love this
so here's what we did the tool that we
adopted and I'll tell you about it in a
second helps to build a road map where
are you now not where you thought you
were but where are you really where are
you now where do you want to go and the
things that you need to do to change and
get better to be in that successful
position you might want to be more
efficient you want might want to
more consistent you may have some sort
of a training problem that you've run
into keep in mind a lot of the data
managers within the scientific community
do not have standard training so right
there you have a problem you probably
have folks with different techniques
which one's better have you even thought
about the fact that one of them is
probably not as good as the other and
then the way we work this is it's tuned
exactly to your organization so what is
it haha so if you know the seam of my
Institute they were spun off of an
organization called the software
engineering Institute which was an FF
rdc at a Carnegie Mellon so this they
have models software acquisition and
services they call them their
constellations so several years ago this
built their data management maturity
model and it was published in August of
2014 I was one of the peer reviewers so
that's how I knew about it and when AG
was looking for someone to implement
this model I was delighted I was so
excited there are seven of us certified
to implement the model we're not proud
of that number we're really hoping
there'll be others so if you're
interested in knowing about it and you
want to try to find have a tool in north
and be part of this community I would
love to talk to you about it the more
the merrier but it's it's a it's a tough
bar to jump to be able to be certified
to do this and there are 25 different
process areas and I'll give you a view
of what those are in a moment but let me
tell you how we're using this so within
the research within the scientific
research community it's not like an
organization such a commercial
organization where everything that's
managing the data is within the CEOs
command but it's not like that well we
have our different roles in multiple
communities that I'll have to work
together to do something to make it
change to make something better and
these are all the different ones have
funders can be anything from the
government to a sloan Foundation to
something to that effect different
publishers for profit not-for-profit
repositories are sometimes only funded
for five years sometimes they're full
blown one
your archives dated managers and the
researchers themselves actually
generating the data and libraries play
an important role as well so not
everyone realizes that there's so many
people involved in making these
decisions that have to work together we
do a lot of collaborative conversations
we set up a lot of collaborative
meetings to make changes so that means
we also fly together great picture yes
the hummingbirds a little big so yes
whoops so here here's the I chart for
you actually i have i have yet one more
eye chart but for each one of these
different pieces of the lifecycle this
is sort of a generic research life cycle
within our community we have i don't
know about 20 different ones that people
like but they're all fairly similar and
this one pretty much matches the general
life cycle something to know you don't
necessarily go sequentially sometimes
within this life cycle you have to go
back redo and keep moving forward which
is why there's the inner hub but each of
the process areas that are part of the
model aligned toward life cycle
extremely well and then we have in
addition to those the ones that are on
the right hand side which cross over the
entire capability so it's very difficult
to know if you're improving unless
you're measuring it's very difficult to
know if you have consistent practices
across your team members about checking
their quality and there are fairly easy
ways to do this and people can get
strung up on the fact that i'm talking
about it as being measurement and
analysis we're actually all i want to
know is are we at seeing the same
getting worse or getting better and
can't we just make that an easy number
to do so it usually help you through all
that so we've only tell you about two
assessments we've done so what an
assessment is is we prepare an
organization for us to come in and spend
about a week with them and find out in
granular detail exactly what they do and
we've done that for these groups that
are right here
two different kinds of groups one within
a government agency so that's USGS
that's a long tail repository that also
houses community data like projects like
a project team including by the way so
that you know how awesome this database
is our national maps are held within the
sciencebase so when you want to get a
map from the geologic survey they get it
out of this database which is pretty
awesome and the other one is a NSF
funded organon organization specific to
biological and chemical oceanography
data another top-notch group so I'm
going to walk you through this very
quickly so science base I gave you kind
of a high-level view who they are and so
they provide web services and content
management and one of the reasons we
chose them as a we had worked with them
to do the assessment is they are looking
to implement this is some months back at
this point but they were looking to come
up with a way to scale and
implementation for the data release
policy the one that ostp came out and
said your research and data shall be
available so so like okay there's just a
few of us how do we do that ah no
problem let's talk about that so we work
through each of those items and they're
here they're data management objectives
and they actually had some fairly lofty
ones because they have a lot of
regulation and requirements within as a
government agency itself and one to
highlight for you is they also wanted to
be recognized from the publishing houses
as an actual repository that was
complying with all of the requirements
from publishers which are pretty steep
including age use so we help we help
them work through all of that so the
good news story here is I just had a
follow-up meeting with them last week I
saw them at International Data week and
they have their almost completed
implementing all of their initiatives
they are ready to go fully loaded for
the October first requirement for
having data available and they have an
entire group of folks that they have
brought in from across USGS in order to
help be dated managers and extend their
capability so they've trained people
across their entire footprint so it was
a fantastic story bigger demo which is
how you say that acronym the this is a
this is a group we were talking
yesterday about open link data one of
the reasons I was excited to come here
to do an assessment is there one of the
repositories that's furthest along on
being able to share their data through a
link because within the scientific
community we don't we don't encourage a
whole lot of copying we don't once it's
in a repository would rather you link to
it although copying does happen so that
can be another briefing but they are
solving the problem by a very robust
implementation of open like data and
that's working really well so as we as
we went through each of these went
through their elements they were very
robust organization what they were
looking from the assessment was an
opportunity to be ready for the midterm
review for their NSF grant they wanted
to be essentially a center of excellence
and they felt they had gotten that out
they also got some standardized data
management training and we help them
move think through they had several p
eyes PS and cope eyes that were about to
retire so they needed to have sustained
some way to sustain and be consistent
through that transition so we help them
with that one of the things that we do
with these assessments we do have a
confidentiality agreement so what I'm
telling you they've already said in a
public way so you need to know more
details about it I can connect you with
the folks that were there and they were
likely to be willing to share and their
experiences so for that I will leave it
there so let me tell you about other
kinds of objectives that folks have
within our community there are some
certifications actually they're fairly
new
data seal of approval and the world data
system have actually come together and
last week announced their new
certification program which is now
combined and it's actually a very
terrific basic program and what it
defines as a series of services that any
particular data repository should have
that's pretty good I'm going to talk to
you a little bit more about it Nestor is
an extension I believe they're out of
Germany and then the iso standard won
6-3 6-3 this is for trustworthy digital
repositories this is a pretty steep
standard this is something that was
actually developed by the planetary
systems with heavy influence coming from
NASA very steep and the the level of
analysis and requirements is on at the
same level as the the model that we're
using for the dmm the difference between
the two is if you know what an iso
standard is you've either met it or you
didn't there's no middle ground but when
you work with in a process improvement
capability like a maturity model you're
able to actually figure out where you
are on that spectrum so if you actually
don't have enough resource or funds to
actually meet that standard because
there's some financial resources that
are required then you could actually
meet it at an eighty percent level and
know where you are that doesn't mean
you're in the standard but it doesn't
mean you're on your way which is a heck
of a lot better than not doing it at all
alrighty so self assessments are out
there I'm going to put this up here you
can read the words but my great example
here is consider the fact that you you
want to live healthier and you know that
you need to go out and work out for 45
minutes three times a week okay great so
somebody says to me shall i do you work
out for 45 minutes three times a week
though yeah yeah I sure do yeah so then
I get a trainer okay Shelly do you work
out 45 minutes three times a week well
well let me tell you that walk to the
metro to my office ah not really so big
difference between having some would
facilitate your conversations so you
realize how a particular requirement or
practice actually should be working for
your environment so instead of you
saying no no no that's not for me the
facilitator says yes yes yes I'm so
sorry actually this will benefit you and
let me explain why by the time I'm done
explaining they're like oh my gosh yes
of course it will benefit me so pick
your favorite these are all of the
different data management process area
so just eyeball these and kind of get to
get them in your head and you'll
understand why in a moment I'm going to
give you one more here's another these
are things that keep your processing
consistent and sustainable over time
this means that your organization is
actually supporting what's happening
through policy and procedures and
training and making sure the right
people are in place okay so there's
there's that set if you're ready okay
cab those in your head so along the left
side are all the elements of the iso
standard 1 6-3 6-3 along the top are all
the elements of the data management a
charity models starting with the process
areas and the consistency and
sustainment they're broken into two
sections on the right one of them are
that's a demarcation for a couple
different levels so the great thing here
is you don't have to have every box
filled in the really great thing here is
that every column has at least some sort
of green box terrific this is
outstanding alignment although I did
find one weakness and they know this I
shared this with that so the one on the
left hand side there is a standard
vocabulary or glossary or taxonomy we
would all agree that that would be
important and the one on the far right
having having to do with keeping
sustainment is the capturing of your use
cases when something actually happens
and you need to be able to make a change
in the process you need to be writing
them down so those both those things
would be good so my message to them was
hey if we use the dmm to reach your
standard i'll include those two things
and don't worry so here's the starter
cat
certification ideas data seal of
approval a world data system requirement
and they actually talk about theirs as
being fairly lightweight and this
demonstrates yes that's fairly
lightweight and the message here is
there's very little having to do with
sustainability which is a concern
because we have organizations out there
that are adopting this not realizing
that all they're getting is a checkmark
of services and not necessarily a whole
sustaining environment for the
repository it is a fabulous start though
if you can get here then you can keep
going so this is a great first effort so
that would be my message here so just
for your just for your summary if we can
manage our data better we can also do
our science better scientist can find
data more easily they can use it for
future effort and this is really
important to a GU the assessments can
help you reach any goal and education
can help you as well we're finding that
some folks don't even realize what the
different data management best practices
are so starting with education will be
fantastic an assessment when you're
ready and the model works for anything
not just earth and space science it
works anything for anything so it's
currently being used heavily within the
financial community and they're bringing
it into a believe medical devices pretty
soon so thank you